Nous avons des contrats et comme je l'ai signalé
Ministère de la Défense Civile
lignes et gtlk et autres locations
société fait partie des hélicoptères A par
avec les avions, tout est pareil avec nous
en tenant compte de ces tests de certification et
programmes de remplacement des ports superjet
MS-21
complètement non
Eh bien, qu'est-ce que je vous dis, laissez-moi vous dire
maintenant après avoir terminé la réunion qu'avec
nous allons plonger avec toi Pourquoi m'ai-je
Je sais qu'il n'y a pas de contrats dans les entreprises
les réalisateurs m'ont dit Eh bien, vraiment
le fou traîne
Quand il y aura, c'est de ça que je parle
pas de directeur non